the security council gathered for its
fifth briefing on the situation in
ukraine in three weeks the united
kingdom one of six countries to call for
it we want to continue to hold russia to
account
for the war crimes that are being
carried out there
we want to counter their disinformation
and lies
as images of that bomb theater
sheltering families in mariopol circled
the globe three u.n officials briefed
citing at least 700 ukrainians killed so
far in the conflict dozens of them
children 5 million forced to flee their
homes as damage to civilian
infrastructure including 43 health
facilities mounts
russia denied bombing the theater and
targeting civilians
ukraine always was a pawn in the
geopolitical struggle against russia and
remains such a pawn still western
politicians couldn't care less about the
suffering of the people in dunbas
including women children and the elderly
the briefing took place a day before the
security council was expected to vote on
a humanitarian resolution put forth by
russia but nato aligned council members
made clear they wouldn't support
anything that didn't point the finger
directly at russia as the source of that
humanitarian crisis so russia changed
plans
we know if russia really truly cared
about humanitarian
crises the one that it created it could
simply stop its attacks on the people of
ukraine
but instead they want to call for
another security council meeting to use
this council as a venue for its
disinformation and for promoting its
propaganda russia now plans to discuss
u.s bio labs in ukraine saying it has
new evidence to share
we have this information which is raging
much much on a much greater scale than
the than the battle then on the
battlefield and i will not be surprised
at anything because
who wins the the information war the one
wins the war
intense diplomatic activity continues
i think we have to be very realistic
a lot of this is diplomatic game playing
it's not actually going to have a huge
impact on the ground but the us and its
allies are looking for every way they
can to put pressure on russia lots of
talk on the part of the security council
but still no action kristen salumi al
jazeera the united nations